it may not get the same recognition as
ve day
but vga day was every bit as significant
with germany defeated and hitler dead
japan held firm
and the war continued in the pacific
until the united states dropped atomic
bombs on two japanese cities
forcing their surrender seventy-five
years on
roy miller remembers the campaign in the
far east vividly
1943 was lamb scotland he joined the
royal navy at the age of 15
and ended up on hms indomitable
responsible for shooting down kamikaze
pilots
my job was to defend her if she was
attacked and from time to time
they did come at us with kamikaze
attacks
that wasn't really pleasant because you
had to shoot them down otherwise they're
going to blow into you and knock you
out we had several nasty experiences
and we knocked a few of them down and
there is a trickle of fear runs through
you
you know he's going to get you always
after you he's going to hit the ship
he's going to do it he's got to be shot
down you've got to kick you're going to
go next to him
you've got to keep your nerve roy says
that on august 15
1945 for him there was no euphoria
just one very distinct feeling it wasn't
joy at all it was a relief
to really realize that no you know this
was an end
i mean some people say well don't you
don't you celebrate
i didn't celebrate anything it was a
feeling of relief
that the whole thing was coming to an
end
the allied effort in the far east was
very much a multicultural one
with troops from all over the
commonwealth taking part in what was at
times
brutal combat the japanese were the most
spiritual fighters under the sun
they believed that when you are captured
as a prisoner in a war you have
disgraced your entire family
but when you die
it's a great honor to the whole family
you can just imagine such a mentality
more than 70
000 british and commonwealth troops died
in the war against japan
among them more than twelve thousand
prisoners of war who died in japanese
captivity
roy is 96 now and says he will mark the
day by remembering those he served with
who weren't so fortunate and the brady
sky
news